[Musica]
Buongiorno buonasera grazie a Giulia
Grazie Valerio per l'invito il fuoco
oggi appunto è la Madonna del fuoco
fuoco che arte fuoco che non arde se non
ci sarebbe ancora la Madonna del Fuoco
quindi il fuoco non è detto che sia una
cosa sola come dicevano giustamente
prima in genere si associa il fuoco alla
passione il fuoco della passione Valerio
ricordava a Forlì città con l'accento
ovviamente a Forlì non ci poteva essere
la Madonna della camomilla o la Madonna
del Melo Ma c'è la Madonna del fuoco
perché è gente i Romagnoli in generale
ma i Forlivesi abbastanza appassionati
no c'era un grande poeta del passato che
diceva che i Romagnoli hanno questa
forte passione per cui anche se devono
difendere una cosa da niente La
difendono con un grande una grande forza
un grande entusiasmo Ecco la passione in
genere viene associata all'idea del
Fuoco io non so vorrei fare come una
specie di sondaggio Non so se si può
fare durante i Ted Ma chi di voi in
questo momento
una passione sente di avere una passione
forte sulle mani
siamo 96%, quindi direi che ecco perché
la passione è qualcosa che brucia
qualcosa a volte che fa anche bruciare
energie che fa bruciare A volte anche
risorse uno si rovina a volte per certe
passioni No allora io oggi vorrei
fermarmi un po' su
l'importanza della passione Però anche
il fatto che bisogna stare attenti e non
scambiare due cose che si assomigliano
ma non sono la stessa cosa perché una
cosa è l'entusiasmo e una cosa la
passione
chi sa un po' di greco sai che la parola
entusiasmo vuol dire che a un certo
punto vieni preso come da un Dio
ti entra un Dio dentro e ti entusiasmo
Cioè ti rende per poco tempo in genere
l'entusiasmo dura poco per poco tempo
infervorato per qualcosa
è il motivo per cui a volte siamo presi
da quelle che pensiamo essere grandi
passioni che però durano poco durano a
volte pochi minuti pochi giorni poco
tempo e dice Cos'è una passione che si è
spenta no bisogna stare attenti a non
confondere
l'entusiasmo con la passione
L'entusiasmo è appunto un Dio che ti
prende che ti afferra Come sono i Greci
che ti entra dentro e per breve tempo ti
accende per qualcosa È bello avere degli
entusiasmi è importante avere
l'entusiasmi ma è anche importante non
confondere gli entusiasmi con la
passione
perché la passione invece è un altro
tipo di fuoco è un fuoco diciamo così
che ha una durata più lunga
la vera traduzione della parola passione
che come molti sanno viene dal latino
patior significa diciamo così ciò per
cui sei disposto a soffrire
la passione vera È ciò per cui sei
disposto a soffrire Tant'è vero che la
parola passione indica anche la passione
della Via Crucis Gesù Cristo la passione
non è quell'entusiasmo che ti prende e a
volte lasciandoti anche un po'
interdetto ti abbandona la passione è
quella cosa che nel tempo fa vedere ciò
per cui sei disposto a soffrire le vere
passioni Infatti sono non molte nella
vita e sono quelle a cui ti dedichi
veramente a cui sei disposto a
sacrificare tempo energie A volte anche
a sacrificare la faccia a perdere la
faccia per certe passioni perché capisci
che vale la pena soffrire per ciò che ha
suscitato questa passione Questo è il
motivo per cui la passione vera è il
traino della vita non l'entusiasmo
l'entusiasmo molto spesso ci lascia
uguali a prima le passioni invece
possono cambiare la vita Possono
portarti su strade differenti possono
farti cambiare Possono farti farti fare
dei progetti che non immaginavi questo
sono le passioni gli entusiasmi invece
in genere sono dei fuochi brevi anche
interessanti per certi aspetti Ma che ti
lasciano in genere come prima bisogna
distinguere non sempre facile ma credo
che un segno che ci faccia capire la
differenza tra passione entusiasmo cioè
tra il fuoco che veramente crea che
veramente crea vita che è la passione e
l'entusiasmo invece che in genere è
passeggero uno dei segni che si fa
distinguere tra queste due cose e
appunto che la passione ti fa ti porta a
soffrire per qualcosa no in genere
quando si dice anche tra innamorati Tu
sei la mia passione si dice o anche con
i figli Tu sei la mia passione
con quella parola si dice qualcosa che
sai che ti piace molto diciamo così ma
anche qualcosa a cui stai dando molto
qualcosa che ti sta chiedendo molto Tu
sei la mia passione in genere non si
dice è un rapporto da poco si dice un
rapporto è diventato importante un
rapporto che significativo e che non
solo ti entusiasma ma molto spesso ti
chiede anche qualcosa ti chiede
parecchio anche per questo sei la mia
passione è una espressione bellissima Io
spero che tutti voi abbiate molte
persone a cui dire tu sei la mia
passione questo indica una vita generosa
Infatti da cosa si vede e può sembrare
un paradosso Ma se siamo qui anche per
dirci delle idee un po' paradossali dei
non solite da cosa si vede che una delle
passioni
dal fatto che è sempre agitato dal fatto
che è sempre su di giri No il fatto che
è paziente
le vere passioni di morsi dimostrano
Innanzitutto come pazienza
è la stessa radice patior passione
pazienza c'è il fatto che sono le cose a
cui dedichi Pazienza le cose che
meritano la tua passione le cose che
veramente meritano la tua passione
allora un uomo veramente appassionato e
può sembrare strano e invece un uomo
paziente un uomo che ha grande passione
è un uomo di grande pazienza
è un uomo di grande capacità di pazienza
con le cose che meritano la sua passione
che ha dei figli tra voi sa benissimo
cosa intendo perché non c'è cosa che ti
strappa la pazienza come i figli ma non
finisce mai la pazienza coi figli ma
anche con le persone che si amano con
gli amici con le persone che si amano
Ecco questo può sembrare strano Perché
in genere Noi mettiamo in correlazione
la passione invece una sorta di
fibrillazione continua No una specie di
emozione Continua su di giri no c'è
l'uomo che è sempre su di giri è uno che
si tiene su di giri perché sennò non si
sente vivo l'Uomo di passione invece
vive di grandi pazienza di grandi
passioni profonde di grandi sofferenze
anche di grandi dedizioni
perché tra i fuochi nella notte un po'
che è la vita tra i fuochi bisogna
Distinguere come quando i naviganti sono
nel Mare oscuro si possono vedere dei
riflessi di specchietti si possono
vedere di vetri si possono vedere di
piccoli fuochi oppure ogni tanto devi
capire quali sono i fuochi che indicano
veramente la strada una volta quando non
c'erano gli strumenti
elettronici i radar i marinai si
orientavano coi fuochi delle stelle i
fuochi remoti delle stelle o i fuochi
che qualcuno accendeva sulle Isole o
all'imbocco dei porti nella notte un po'
che è la vita bisogna distinguere il
fuoco che guida se la passione se
l'entusiasmo
se la brevità di certe entusiasmi
passeggeri Questo è il compito
dell'esistenza il compito del viaggio
per fortuna allora in Romagna c'è la
passione c'è la Madonna del fuoco che
forse si può indicare qualche fuoco da
seguire e io per finire volevo lasciarvi
con una poesia visto che è l'unica cosa
che so fare scrivere poesie è una poesia
che è dedicata a dei piccoli fuochi che
ogni tanto si vedono Io ho dei figli
quel giorno era in moto e portavo mio
figlio verso la casa dove abitano sui
Boschi sopra Bologna ed è successo
questa cosa per chi i fuochi il grande
fuoco della vita il grande fuoco della
passione a volte si vede anche in fuochi
piccoli se stai attento anche in piccoli
fuochi
e poi voltando in moto sulla curva che
mette sui crinali il figlio più piccolo
attaccato alle spalle viene il buio
della Valle un istante di respiro
interrotto e inizia il miracolo minimo
incantato le lucciole sfiora nei
cespugli i lunghi rami oscuri ridono gli
occhi e Tace il puma del mio cuore non
avrò ricchezza da lasciarti ragazzino
che porterà il mio nome e quello di mio
padre ma quando c'è una curva da fare e
non sai cosa ti può aspettare prepara
gli occhi prepara il cuore il mondo non
è solo quel che è più forte appare più
forte grida più a fondo tira stai
attaccato bene alle mie spalle poi
quando la mia figura sarà un albero
nella notte guida tu al cielo attacca la
tua fronte offri Gioia ira pianto
non c'è curva Senza sorpresa da scoprire
E ora che le mie stanno finendo è bello
trovarsi a un nuovo inizio così dolce e
tremendo nelle notti mentre tu sorridi
le lucciole ammirando
[Applauso]
[Musica]